and the Oscar goes to Emma Stone la
la I want to thank dami and chazelle for
the opportunity to be part of a project
that was so special once in a lifetime
and Ryan Gosling thank you for making me
laugh and for always raising the bar and
for being the greatest partner on this
crazy
adventure um to our whole crew everyone
that put their Heart and souls into this
film I I'm going to find you all
individually and I'm going to thank you
along with my friends who I love so much
I'm going to hug the hell out of you
when the feeling re-enters my body um
I I still have a a lot of growing and
learning and work to do and this guy is
a really beautiful symbol to continue on
that journey and I'm so grateful for
that so thank you so much thank
you